on this episode of Star Talk it is star
talk live at Pioneer Works in Brooklyn
my comedic co-host is Paul mariro and
our special guest is cosmologist Jan 11
and we talk about my latest book
co-written with our longtime senior
producer of Star Talk Lindsay Walker and
after that we talk about Einstein's
greatest blunder we talk about Edwin
Hubble the man not the telescope and a
lot more coming up on start
[Music]
talk first up the humor part comes from
a professional standup comedian who is a
participant in practically every episode
that we post tonight we have our friend
and one of my favorite Comics around
Paul mrio Paul come on up where are
you good Paul you Paul you got a podcast
of your own I do and and it was uh
creatively called what it's called ins
see he's insulting my the title of my
podcast already okay uh inside out with
Paul mrio inside out with Paul mcyo yes
okay all right I've been a guest on his
podcast and we had a great time at the
planetarium yes we did yeah yes and then
a few drinks and we broke a couple of
things but uh that's right so thanks for
coming on for this thank you for having
this a live thing this is an amazing
space I've never been here this
turnout's amazing I'm really excited and
then we're all going to go swimming
after this just right well in the in the
in the East River here okay next up we
all know and L her is Jan she is
Professor Jan L Janet come on
up Jan 11 does she need an introduction
in this space I don't think so but we'll
do so anyway so you're tow professor of
TOA to to to Professor of physics and
astronomy at Barnard College of Columbia
University where we first met it is and
you're director of science here at
Pioneer Works Brooklyn in the house
yes editor-in chief of the pioneer Works
podcast author of How the Universe Got
Its Spots one of my favorites uh black
hole Survival
Guide it doesn't end well just you know
spoiler alert you don't survive that
okay and also one of my favorites the
black hole Blues and other songs from
outer
space that's how you want me to say it
all the time I want you to say it all
the time the black hole blues and so in
fact tonight we are going to focus on
the fourth section of the book which is
really where the title of the book takes
shape to infinity and beyond places
where our bodies can't go but our minds
can so let's begin here right now in
Brooklyn let's do it all right
okay I love being a guest on this stage
by the way oh yeah no I love that you're
the host this is so fun for me I got you
so yeah so you can just chill yeah and
and and we have questions for you to for
us to understand
so in the book it's about upheavals in
our understanding of how the world works
and how we reacted to that were we
elegant and graceful or do we get
dragged into the future Kicking and
Screaming not all stories in the history
of science have smooth sort of
journalistic burn the Midnight Oil and
say Eureka at the end so so let's detail
some of the weirdest wackiest ideas in
the universe and you got to start with
who Einstein Einstein that was just a
good guess yeah so his his theory
special and general theory of relativity
and you're an expert on that right oh
absolutely just checking uh so so tell
us about Einstein's biggest blunder and
we talk about this in in the book just
because this is some of the fits and
starts that we go through to understand
the universe so what what's going on
with I I love this about him because
here he is dreaming these dreams that
defy everything everyone else took for
granted but then he has a moment of like
resistance and it's emotional resistance
he wants to believe the universe is
permanent that it didn't have a
beginning and it won't have an end and
that it's like static he wants that
that's an emotional response and even in
his own mathematical
Theory uh he's surprised when other
people study it and tell him it predicts
a beginning of the universe and an end
to the universe his own Theory isct
could handle it he couldn't handle it he
couldn't handle the trth did you ever
stop he couldn't handle the trth maybe
maybe he just was exhausted at that
point he's like I've done all this I
know some of it's wrong but I just I
need to I need a I need a year off I
need some drinks like maybe that was the
issue for the guy well crazily enough
the guy almost can't be wrong even when
he tries so he he introduces what he
calls a cosmological constant which is
just a term that's mathematically
consistent with the general theory of
relativity but he he he he declined
initially to include it because it made
no sense it came out of nowhere he
couldn't explain it he couldn't justify
it but what it allowed him to do
mathematically was precariously balance
the universe so that it was static but
it was very very unstable soul and when
he realized that he was like right so
just so people are on the same page I
know you guys are scientifically
literate here but just to make sure you
can balance a marble at the top of a
hill and
that's that that's a point of
equilibrium but it's not stable because
any gust of wind will send it one way or
the other yes and in this case the gust
of wind Would S the universe Contracting
or expanding whereas if the marble were
at the bottom of a hill it's also it's
also a point of equilibrium but it's
stable because you can displace it and
it'll always return to that spot and
that's what he was hoping for he was
hoping that if you try to make the
universe expand or contract not be
static and permanent that it would
actually prefer to stabilize but it
doesn't it's actually very very hard to
stabilize the universe and as we know
today the universe is in fact expanding
so Einstein was an idiot you're saying
yeah but what was it I mean there
there's a quote in the book where you
say with the notion of a static Universe
firmly anchored in its philosophical
substrate Einstein developed his general
theory of relativity and it embodies his
Assumption of a stagnant Universe even
though his own equations reveal the
unsettling truth so he he must have
known why couldn't he get his head
around that reality I think that's
nobody really knows I don't know if
there was really a sense of
investigating with him why he was so
resistant to the predictions of really
his fault who would have been the first
to say the
universe has a beginning I mean religion
said it but
scientifically there's no FR reference
frame to even have that thought no it's
really stunning it's the first time
there is a
scientific uh concept of a beginning a
big bang beginning list I think it's
clear the guy was closed off emotionally
and you got the
so tell me about L they looked at
Einstein's equations which he wrote down
after lots of fits and starts he used to
say things like if you're you think you
have troubles in mathematics mine are
greater it's amazing he kind of made it
into the cannon really that he wasn't
just sort of Forgotten and excluded he's
studying this and he says you know if I
imagine a universe where everything is
kind of smooth and uniform the whole
universe and I ask how does space and
time time respond to a universe full of
stuff as long as it's kind of smooth you
know it's a very simple system but not
that far off from actually what we
observe but uh he realized that in
response to a universe full of stuff it
wants it wants to either expand or
contract all right so it doesn't want to
just sit there so did he finally agree
to this I say yeah he he he agrees after
Hubble in the 20s Hubble the human being
Hubble the human being not the after
whom the satellite is named um is up
there just a satellite it's
pretty it's a telescope satellite it's a
telescope satellite it is thank you an
amazing phenomenon Hubble looks out at a
smudge on this sky and he's not sure
what it is and he's trying to figure out
is it a Nova which would be a nearby
object that's very bright or is it a
distant Galaxy and and much brighter and
much more distant and there's an actual
plate uh photographic plate that he took
where he crosses out no o and he writes
V with an exclamation point a variable
star and it makes him realize because of
his understanding of variable stars that
it's a bright object far away very far
and that's that's based on levit right
Henry classified this variety of
variable star that turned out to be
crucial to understanding the distances
to objects so leave it to a woman there
you go made it happen good job great
unbelievable story actually about
Henrietta levit and all that that whole
crew of female astronomers around the
turn of the previous Century they were
called pickering's Harum because Charles
Pickering who is the director of
Harvard's Observatory hired them for 25
cents on the dollar after he fired all
of the male astronomers because they
weren't doing a good job and he said my
Scotch maid could do a better job and he
hired her which is Willamina Fleming and
she hired all these women and they
became this cluster of phenomenal
observational astronomers unsung heroes
they died in poverty penurious and a
book highlighting their care Davis Davis
soel that's right called the glass
ceiling no no the glass Universe glass
Universe we had Dava here to talk about
that book yeah and and um it's an it's
an incredible story but Hubble knew
about that work which is remarkable if
he did not know about these unknown
women and their work that they were
doing at the Harvard Observatory he
would not have understood that he was
not looking you know if you just imagine
a light bulb up close that he wasn't
looking at something up close but he was
looking at something much much brighter
that was very far away and so we are now
in the Centennial decade of Hubble's
major discoveries as well as the
Centennial decade we are 1922 exactly of
most of the discoveries of quantum
physics so that was a watershed decade
right there the
1920s so fast forward to
1998 and we discover a value for
Einstein's
constant that's that's insane it's
insane so this is what I meant he can't
even make a mistake so he introduces
this thing to try to make the universe
not expand Hubble comes along and says I
saw this galaxy it's really far away and
then I saw a bunch of them and they're
all moving away from us the universe is
expanding the whole universe is the
whole universe is expanding we're not at
the center we're just part we're also
moving away from everything else it's
the whole thing question the age of the
universe and if any of those numbers are
right and all of that and we find out
that not only is the universe expanding
it's
accelerating by the power of this term
in Einstein's equation so in fact the
term does exist crazy so even when
Einstein was wrong he was right he was
right exactly so everyone's like
Einstein that's badass get rid of that
constant it's a big blunder and then in
1998 long after Einstein passed they
realized oh actually the only thing we
can think of not just to make the
universe expand but to make it expand
faster and faster to accelerate is the
cosmological constant his biggest
blunder okay it turns out to be right so
if we're expanding that means yesterday
smaller than today and the day before
smaller than that and I'm shrinking then
and if you go back in time there's got
to be a point where the whole universe
is occupying one spot it had a beginning
oh my God that's lamea coming in which
is actually very interesting I wonder
why Einstein was more resistant to the
idea of an expanding Universe than a
Catholic who had to confront the idea
that the Universe was ancient and had a
beginning right I mean I think that's
the beginning part was easy because
Genesis is but not 6,000 years ago yeah
yeah yeah 14 billion years yeah billions
of years ago so so if it had a beginning
and it's expanding does Universe have an
edge and by the way these questions is
that any different from sitting here on
Earth and saying how do I get to the
moon I don't know pose the question and
you heard in this exchange that the
answers to the theories had to wait for
experiments to join the conversation you
can't just sit in an armchair and claim
you under fully understand the universe
so does the universe have an edge are
you asking Paul or me Paul does the
universe have an edge uh I think it does
I've been to the edge and uh no it's uh
it's the Hamptons and yeah some people
have edges so what in the context of
this in the book you talk about the
human ego right and there's an
interesting uh concept there which
really sort of surprised me and and what
you say is that um uh given the battles
uh that rag etc etc you you say we know
the universe is expanding um blah blah
blah the ultimate defining barrier
between uh space and well not space
however yeah there's a lot of stuff by
the way the book needs more pictures
um you know it's like oh look look a
spaceship woohoo um no it's a great book
uh to fall asleep and uh I think I'm
never coming back on the show again
so uh no so in all seriousness this is a
quote from the book uh we know the
universe is expanding and that expanded
from a single point furthermore
everything in the universe must obey a
speed limit reason would dictate that
the Universe must therefore have an edge
however reasonable though that might
sound it arises from a faulty premise
driven in part by the human ego and I
was fascinated to know what you meant by
that driven by in part by the human ego
well an ego just are you in the center
of everything the authentic Center if
you learn you're not in the center how
do can you deal with that can you handle
you can because no sitting just think
about it and we detail this once again
in our Ascent from Earth into the solar
into the solar system you we you say to
yourself
um we're in the
center by the way we made calendars not
knowing calendars we still use today not
knowing Earth went around the Sun yes
but there were adorable they have
puppies on them no they're all good so
so you can deduce a whole lot about the
world without telescopes well one of the
things you cannot deduce is that Earth
is going around the Sun that's that's
messed up okay that meant we went
thousands of years thinking we're in the
center of the known universe fully
feeding our ego but why wouldn't you and
when there's no proof of anything else
and all seriousness why why what other
premise would you would you you're being
too hard on uh you know
prece civilizations what are issues that
you have inside of you no what I'm
saying is you need a hug the whole
universe come here you need need
a the whole
universe is masquerading
as a system centered on us so we're not
given reason to question it because it
feeds our ego when something feeds your
ego you say yeah it's probably true
not asking well maybe it's not true
because maybe it's not true could have
the result that you're not in the center
but think about the ego you have to have
as these great astronomers and
scientists to say I'm going to go and
look into something that no one else has
done and then stand by it and believe in
it before anyone else does that's not
ego that's curiosity no but you've got
to have an ego to be stand by something
I think no yeah that no that's then
you're then you're
stubborn I'll fight you right now
yeah if you have an idea and you stick
by it regardless of the data go home
that's not what science is about that's
what Absolut which is why we discuss not
having debates over science because
nobody no scientist worth their assault
wants to come in with a notion and be
unyielding or unwilling to to accept a
new idea or or or adopt it when it's
clearly right so two scientists in an
argument there's a different contract
between them than there is between two
people debating on a state
so that contract is either I'm right and
you're wrong you're right and I'm wrong
or we're both wrong so we'll argue until
we get to the edges of what our data can
show and then we say you know I think we
need better data let's go have a beer
yeah right said no one ever at the end
of a political
debate so so so but the idea of the
infinite Universe kind of fell into that
category because when Einstein was first
writing things down and he was just
doing the first pass so to speak and and
he has a famous quote where you know he
assumed the universe was infinite but he
also assumed it was static and he said
uh something to the effect only two
things are infinite the universe and
human stupidity yeah best best quote
ever and then he added and I'm not so
sure about the universe that's right I
forgot about that is isn't it a matter
of the Ed obser observable Edge versus
there's an observable Edge for sure so
we can only see as far as the light has
had a chance to get to us but it's not a
physical edge of the universe it's not a
physical Edge so you can't you can't
drive through the universe and say
universe ends here well we don't think
so but we're not actually 100% sure we
don't believe that there's an edge any
more than there's an edge to the Earth
like to the surface of the Earth there's
not a sign to the edge of the universe
right so you know if I travel from New
York City and I go in a straight line I
don't fall off the edge of the Earth
right right there's no Edge I make my
way all the way around and I come back
to New York City again and that's
actually a really valid model for a
universe that is finite not infinite in
which you go into a spaceship you leave
the Earth you travel in a straight line
you go out of the Galaxy you don't
deviate and you find yourself
approaching the Milky Way Again with the
Earth in front of you and you've never
fallen off the edge of the universe it's
completely contiguous but it is finite
so I have to repeat a quote from one of
my earlier books the universe is under
no obligation to make sense to
you tell me about the intersection of
time and space which feels so
unintuitive but actually we exist this
way the example I give is if I say oh
Janna uh I'll meet you tomorrow at 10
o'clock what's your next question where
where I gave you a time but I didn't
give you a space say are you bringing
wine so then I say Paul I'll meet you
tomorrow at Starbucks Buck okay we know
which Starbucks and then you'll have to
say what time what time so you know we
know this intuitively so then Einstein
stitches them together why do people
lose their mind well it I mean it's
amazing because a lot of things he did
were actually really simple and
intuitive um but he pushes it much F
farther where you many people would
start to get flumix and give it up and
just be happy to meet at Starbucks with
a bottle of wine I that doesn't really
make any sense but okay Paul and um but
always go to one with a bathroom you can
do whatever you
want so he starts to think well you know
I can draw up and down north and south
east and west why don't I just also draw
a dimension called time and then we can
just agree on where we are in space and
time and then he kind of pushes that
further and further and further until he
starts to say oh it's a space time and
as that's one phrase one phrase I don't
right I can't I don't like editors out
there I don't like when you put a dash
in there it's
SpaceTime and no no paired words have to
evolve yeah and and then they eventually
lose their hyphen okay but like percent
used to be two words then it was
hyphenated one word but why don't you
like The Hyphen in because it separates
space and time in a way that Einstein
was trying to transcend and in this book
we did not use a hyphen we have editors
that followed suit here so we got
National Geographic editors that's a
National Geographic book okay so so what
that means is that if time is a
coordinate it can stretch or Shrink you
have different rates of Christopher
Nolan did that in in the movie
Interstellar yeah which was by our
friend uh the original treatment was by
Kip Thorne yes who's going come up in
conversation yeah he's your counterpart
at Caltech yeah yes well that's a
compliment thank totally totally um no
Kip was one of the most gracious you
know Elder Statesmen of science when I
first met him is and made him an
executive producer of interstellar so
that meant you knew the science had some
backbone and then he won a Nobel Prize
really weird Order of Things yes yes
chronologically weird order of things
behind that Nobel Prize the real person
was Matthew mccon he gave him all the
information he's a brilliant handome
person behind the Nobel Prize yes yes
hang out in his trailer and math be like
no man that's not how you do it um so
you have if you're nearer a a a
significant source of gravity your time
frame slows down relative to other
people yeah that's that's freaky it's
very freaky but but in Einstein's
language it's no more freaky than the
fact that my left and my right are
rotated relative to your left and your
right in Einstein's language you can
rotate space and
time differently than somebody else's
notion of in a four dimensional
coordinate space yeah in a four
dimensional space yeah that's really
easy to grab there yeah that you know
when you near the black hole it's as
though you're rotating in
SpaceTime just like you could rotate
left and right relative to somebody far
away and just as I won't be like my left
is an absolute notion obviously I'm
rotated and it's relative to your left
if I face you that's my right exactly
100% rotation and he says as you near
the black hole you have 100% rotation of
your space if you're far from the black
hole my time that's near the black hole
it's just like my left being 100%
rotated into your right all right so
what about uh
wormholes and whether we can use that
for time travel that's Kip Thorn or
maybe it's Matthew mccon I'm not really
sure I don't know can we do this without
a DeLorean
yeah which is now by the way on Broadway
this Back to the Future the musical now
on Broadway yes you really said that as
though you were
promoting he's got a piece of the end
well just a just a quick point there uh
to your SpaceTime fact just slip this in
because we have it in in the book If you
go in a time machine and say I want to
go back three days so you go in and then
you step out and it's 3 days
earlier you would be in the vacuum of
empty space cuz Earth isn't a different
place but why is it empty it's still
Earth why are you in a vacuum because
Earth is in orbit around atmosphere went
with it Earth is you you just went back
in time but Earth was in an orbit you go
three days back in time you didn't say
keep me on Earth and do that and the
whole solar system moved the whole Solar
so if you actually want to go back in
time and show up on this stage you have
to go back in time and in space so that
the Earth is where you need it to be at
that time so the SpaceTime thing is real
if you want to if you want a time
machine your way around around the
Galaxy now they got around this in Back
to the Future because he jumps into the
car quickly types in a thing and he goes
back exactly 30
years uh so he's in the same orbit in
the orbit Earth would have been in the
same spot in its orbit but he did he
also calculate for the fact that the
whole solar system is rotating around
the center of the Galaxy for 30 years no
he left that one out you got to give him
a whole pass got one of those right
magical about 30 years in that scenario
it's just because it goes wait it goes
from 198 no no in that scenario it goes
from 1985 the year of the film to
1955 which is a very fun setting to put
a movie in okay because teenagers are
coming of age so Chuck Barry's music
gets stolen it's a great time oh Chuck
Barry's music do you know are we speak
do you have you who has not seen Back to
the
Future okay a hand went up security
could you take this person
out no just a quick point about Chuck
Barry's music um Marvin Berry the
brother or the cousin was he the cousin
what okay here's Marty play Chuck Berry
but that song isn't written yet he holds
up the phone for Chuck Barry to hear
Marty play this Johnny Be Good s was it
Johnny Be Good yeah to play it and he
says Chuck this is the sound you've been
looking for okay so holding aside that
it credits a white person for giving
music to a black perform holding that
aside what was say you're holding a lot
aside that's a tun holding that aside uh
there's something called a gin particle
do you know about gin particles these
are things that are neither created nor
destroyed and they involve the time
continuum it's a loop in time where that
song in that movie was never written it
only existed to be handed into a Time
Loop and we call it gin particles
because you can hand a person something
that you then give to me later in time
and that was never created nor it was
destroyed but when she hands you that
later in time you can't say that it
wasn't invented previously no because I
go back in time and give it to her this
is the time travel enables gin particles
to exist this is along the lines in the
book where you talk about sort of you go
back in time with a spaceship and just
before you're about to to leave the day
before you blow up the spaceship right
and then you've got I I wouldn't do that
but yeah go on yeah well it's in your
book yeah no it's a scenario go on and
and where you're talking about parallel
universe right and and sort of how
things break off yes right yeah that's
right so so how do we how does can we
travel backwards in time authentically
well this is all interesting related to
it because you're assuming that the
person who traveled back in time could
make a choice that was
inconsistent with with the physical
Universe actually right and and and Neil
you saying well I wouldn't do that is
actually kind of close to the Bone
because it's really the presumption that
we have a free will that could do
something that defies the laws of
physics so you can completely go back in
time as long as you don't exercise any
free will that deviates from the consist
that BEC that's that's what you call in
the book The Butterfly Effect right like
you go back in time and then you start
this sort of Ripple right but so that
could then change all future events
right but you don't have the option to
do that even if it prevents the birth of
you who then went back in time back up
to prevent that wa so my favorite
example of this is I I see a friend of
mine walking down a corridor and they
slip on a banana peel okay and they get
hurt I don't want my friend to get hurt
so I pull out a new texting service that
uses particles that travel backwards in
time tach on and so I send a text
backwards through time so that my friend
receives the text before he steps on the
banana peel and therefore they don't
fall so I do that but what if the what
if he has his uh phone on airplane mode
and he doesn't get the text well let's
find out so I send the text back my
person uh feels the vibrate picks it up
looks at it and it says watch out for
the banana peel but while they're
looking at it they don't see the banana
peel and they slip on it so the very
fact that I sent the message back in
time is what caused the slippage on the
banana peel and so that's the the the
temporal event laws of physics that
you're referencing yeah strictly
speaking the laws of physics we know
that general
relativity has universes hypothetical
not ones that we've yet observed in
which you can do exactly what you just
described go back in time but there is
no law of physics that we know of that
allows you to do so in a way that is
inconsistent that prevents you from
existing with the exact path that you
are on so the idea of being able to
alter my future by going back in time is
it's very 12 Monkeys yeah
who 12 Monkeys yeah you don't know
you're giving people a hard time about
how did you miss 12 I saw it I for now
and you know Back to the Future for
could that be wrong could what be wrong
could that be wrong right so there was a
there was a a refinement of the process
to figure out the age of the universe
right some that started three billion
and then 5.5 billion or whatever and to
this day right we there could be some
new science that gets discovered that
makes this inaccurate right what we what
we believe now or or some time science
so there's nothing that remains to be
discovered there's nothing absolute
never never is there other than Neil's
handsomeness there is nothing
absolutely and even Kip Thorne who's
come up a couple of times who looked at
this concept of wormholes wormholes were
originally proposed kind of like you
know the Battery Tunnel or something it
was a shortcut from one place to another
you know you or you you go under uh the
East River and you get you connect
Manhattan and Brooklyn not that weird
right to find a shortcut to get from one
place to another but what Kip Thorne did
which was exceptional is he figured out
a way to make that shortcut also
Traverse through time so that you
weren't just traveling from a shortcut
from one space to another space so you
didn't have to go the long way around
but you could actually go earlier in
time oh and they were
worm hes they were time worm holes but I
think if I remember correctly you could
not go back earlier than when oh no then
the time at which the Wormhole was
created oh the weather you could go so
the so none of these things forbid the
possibility that you could go back in
time before you were born kill your
grandfather The Grandfather's Paradox
before he had your mother and then you
were never born you have to kill them
you just have to prevent them from
meeting well it's so it's so Terminator
or slipping on a banana peel just just
or or have them have sex 10 minutes
later than they did Yeah a different
person okay now I'm throwing up in my
mouth a little bit okay no sorry okay
it's actually very much like your banana
peel story because a lot of people think
that the resolution is that if you went
back in time and tried to kill your
grandfather you might just wound him and
then he's so mentally Disturbed that
when he has your mother she's tormented
and traumatized and you're so psychotic
that you go back in time to try to kill
him what happened in both of your
childhoods so so so what you're saying
is that though the Wormhole is like a
doorway that has to exist in at that
point in time or before that point in
time that you want to travel back to he
it was just Kip Thorne's idea for a way
to make that happen without altering the
entire universe a way of doing it
locally so that you don't have to think
of an entire universe that
violates you know time moving forward
do it right here we still constru the
rules of time travel is what this sounds
like yeah yeah okay so so but traveling
to the Future that no problem oh yeah I
can definitely obviously we're all
traveling to the future we are in the
future from where we were at a rate of 1
second per second exactly and none of us
can stop it it's really weird I can
stand still in space more or less but I
can't stand still in time and so right
now this is the future we it's not the
present it's the present but a second
ago we stood on stage is the past we
have traveled we are prisoners of the
present forever transitioning between
our inaccessible past and our unknowable
future that's what happens when you drop
acid before a show
no all right so wait wait can we can we
just go back to that for one
second there can't be there is a present
yes right now yes and there is no future
I can't say that so there's questions
like is this like a hill where the
future exists already and we're just
traveling towards it but it already is
there like a physical Hill or is it kind
of unraveling in front of us
instantaneously that's not a question we
know the answer there a predetermined
Destiny that's scientifically based
that's part of that
question well the you you're not going
to stop the expansion the Universe I
would call that a scientific future I I
would say that if it wasn't for the
pretty big curveball of quantum
mechanics that the answer scientifically
would have been if not for that
curveball that as you pointed out
happened right at this time a century
ago um absolutely predetermined from the
second the universe was created us
sitting here would have been exactly as
it had to be quantum mechanics is a
curveball but it's not a curveball that
really saves us a lot so what is what is
deja vu in in all seriousness like we
all had it right like we're in a moment
where we go I remember feeling this
thing or see it just happened to me the
other day right so is that somehow tied
to this could one argue that it's tied
to all of this now George Carlin argued
that he go he has
vuja which is where he goes into a place
and he's certain he's never been there
before
okay so that's that's me that's right so
I I mean to me this feels in some way I
mean you're not on your are you having
Deja right now I am I feel like I was in
a place before where Neil was telling
that
joke so let we got to bring this to a
close here oh can we talk about the
human ego no free will you talk about
Free Will in the book in the context of
this yeah we do that's a whole that's a
whole it's a really fascinating concept
well then they have to buy the book well
I'm helping you sell the book buddy why
don't you talk to them I can't do
everything Neil I can't write the book
he didn't write the book Lindy wrote the
book
and so so so Janet take us out can you
imagine a future of actual wormholes
that we create or warp drives something
to help us move across the Galaxy with
something other than chemical fuel
Rockets yeah I actually can now but it's
been it's it's really so just like you
build a bridge you know under the water
between Manhattan and Brooklyn you have
to think about tunnel a tunnel under the
water to me they're all bridges wow you
just lost you just lost a lot of
credibility with
me I'm not being a jerk but I know the
difference between a bridge and a tunnel
okay I'm the smartest one on this stage
right now everybody okay good
night so you know about the spherical
cow this is kind of like all physicists
think anything that connects one thing
to another is a brid anything that
connects one thing to another is a
bridge and um you think about how much
energy money it would cost and how how
to do it like what materials you would
need so very similarly when Kip Thorn
and people like that were talking about
wormholes in SpaceTime they were like
what kind of fuel would I need and they
just made it up I know it has to have
certain properties it has to repel it
has to keep this open and they you know
made the wormhole great but then they
looked at the Fuel and they were like
we've never seen anything like this in
the observable universe so nobody knows
of a of a fuel or an energy source that
can do what the Wormhole can do but if
we had that fuel we could build abely
well that was my how does one make a
wormhole and it's very difficult to get
contractors to do work how long does it
take to get someone before they give you
an estimate and actually start on the
time wait plus wormholes as as I
understand it are unstable and if you go
through a wormhole they could collapse
on you in a moment's notice right that
was a real problem is it kept pinching
shut and and and separating the two
space times completely and so you you
know you couldn't make it through
without without being crushed to death
or annihilated but doing that you can
make them stable again if you make up a
form of energy that we don't have never
seen in the universe but it doesn't mean
we never will see I mean Einstein's
greatest blunder you know in 19 when did
he 1916 was General well chy when did he
write it down must have been that same
year 1917 1917 and um it was
19 okay good good you wrote the book
okay good no no you know I don't care
time shut up was good no I was impressed
I made
notes I made notes hang on a second you
just looked at me you talk about the
difference between Bridges and tunnel
I'll be right back there
right no very Paul we're proud of you
it's real good let's talk about c f
no no so so so watch so so the universe
finds a way is all I'm saying okay and
it's not any different from going back
200 years ago and saying in order to get
to the m the moon we need a fuel that
has this amount of energy in it
impossible they they would not be able
to Fathom that and you pack all the
energy into this tube and then you can
reach that they would they would say
what's wrong with you yeah okay so
that's what gives me hope that you can
make a wormhole in the we'll go right to
you when we have the material and then
that would completely transform
transportation in the world the in Star
Trek you wouldn't need the transporter
you just open a wormhole and step down
to the planet much less terrifying than
having all your atoms reassemble of
course exactly is that doable at some
point you think Transporters yeah to
break down your molec done technically
they have teleported
a molecule from one place to another I
mean a molecule taking the energy that
it became all of it facts and and put it
over here them over there yeah yeah okay
and it it it appeared exactly as it was
when
before now we have a lot of facts about
us it's a lot more information than just
the existence of the you two do you got
a lot of
issues right so so just again to around
this to close this out and land This
Plane this rocket uh so I look forward
to a future because that's the whole
Spirit of the book where the next wave
of what happens is beyond the reach of
what we're we can even imagine building
today that's the beyond Infinity see but
this argues against your think in all
seriousness about sort of the
ego thinking we're at the center of the
universe so you were when you were
talking about sort of how they they
found a way to invent fuel to go to the
Moon it it was egoless it was actually
the opposite it was like striving to
find other life right so it works
against that argument doesn't it on some
level about that we're we're ego driven
wait you you're saying we are not ego
driven because of the example of I never
said we were ego driven but I think the
example of the moon is very ego driven
because it was very fueled by the Cold
War when the Soviets put Y garan in
space for the first time Americans
panicked and said you know the
translation we lost our we lost our
and and that that's when the we
know when JFK came out and said hey
space exploration is For All Mankind it
was very egojin in that sense so I mean
we are what we are we're a product of
evolution and maybe the ego was
important in our survival and here we
are or the fact that we can't be
contained in a
box which is also important for our
survival indeed it is well we said that
about Neil you can control them but you
can't contain
them I don't know that' be the last
words of this recording of Star Talk
join me in thanking Janna and our
comedian
[Applause]
[Music]
Paul